welcome everybody to a special episode
of off the rails
in the thanksgiving tradition we are
doing the laugh you die
you laugh you eat
perverted thanksgiving food edition
made by the mad scientists
uh ian and sam together
um
it's disgusting
and uh we're gonna have to eat it in
fact we're not even trying to hide the
fact that we've already
it was great and one of the worst things
i've ever eaten and i just want to die
and lay down same
well today's episode is sponsored by
blender's eyewear
hbo max and honey
dude there's so much ryan kevin off
memes but i'll wait till friday
no this is not not at the dinner table
govern yourself accordingly
i am that's why i'm waiting till friday
to give him his dues
um no leftovers this week you know uh
watch last week's episode where we talk
about
how to own your family on thanksgiving
so if you haven't seen that that is
important thanksgiving is
today
you better watch it so you better
you know
cram
um also very excited to announce we have
a christmas
uh merch line dropping at
h3h3shop.com let's go and i'm also happy
to announce that 100
of the profits from this drop will go to
the crew
yes sir
so
so you know that's a nice little thing
so if you buy this you're directly
supporting these guys that's so cute and
the the i gotta say the designs are
[ __ ] sick [ __ ] fire this is like a
nativity scene is that what it is or no
no no
the nativity is
the birth of jesus
all everybody was in windows watching
jesus be born this is me with big ass
hands of course this is uh we got some
feet we got that we've got the whole
thing even my mom's butterflies making
your dad uh stabbing the beach ball in
the bottom left
on the ninth day of christmas
my true love came to me my dad's
stabbing ten beach balls
a b with the bongos
i love the gatsby on the 12 abs
oh the gatsby's on the roof gets me on
the roof yeah
um
this one
oh this one's the uh
we got to put it in the title the yeti
oh yeah oh it's on the shirt okay it's
so cute shreddy alfredy and yeti oh i
love it
that's shredder alfredo
so cute
so nice shreddy freddy and yeti love
that and then we're in the colorblock
hoodies
of course um
peace and love the whole gang beautiful
it's just a nice design yeah
you know
no [ __ ] no [ __ ] bull the snowman
this this one made by your very own
cameron
wow cameron graham oh cool
uh we're all snowmen and man it just is
so cool great job cam he's so cool so
cool
thanks guys i guess i should say the uh
the advent calendar one was made by my
girlfriend
so beautiful
yeah a lot of talent a lot of talent
going into this one
um this is just a
just a nice little snowflake i like the
simplicity yeah yeah so there you go
guys if you want yourself some christmas
uh
miracle merch and if you want to support
the crew 100 percent goes to them h3
let's go let's go buy that merch yeah
buy that merch okay since jake paul's
once said also uh
just to plug myself here
teddyfresh.com black friday
of the month and also one other thing
one other thing
starting to tease our december drop
some long awaited classics this comes
out december 2nd this is a christmas
sweater the teddy bear family came out
so good
the uh this is a hood this is a jacket
eel has been wearing a lot of people
have been asking about oh this is what
i'm wearing you're wearing it right now
i love that jacket well so there's a
hoodie and a shirt jacket which i'm
wearing the shirt jacket exactly very
cool
oh yeah the gone but not forgotten
dinosaur sweater
yeah and all kinds of cool stuff just
starting to tease it now but
teddy fresh uh on the instagram thank
you is that a client collab i just saw
donna klein collab the butterfly it was
on a butterfly oh that predates yeah
it's just a coincidence
you're right i mean we probably made
that like a year ago that's how the
design process works
yeah
actually it says donna klein will uh
donna kleiners forever let's just pull
yourself together that's also part of
our christmas drop right
okay so there's that
uh there i also have another uh uh
you know exciting announcement this the
island boys have found a sponsor oh god
fashion [ __ ] nova would you guys just
off
i have nothing but disdain for fashion
they literally just sponsor the
shittiest people
they have no they don't care well have
you not seen this no i haven't then
reserve your judgment until you see this
fire ass ad okay well not that they're
shitty but i'm just saying well i guess
they are they're kind of shitty yeah
oh my islam boy i'm a
i'm a fashion nova boy
it's like guys come on bro are they even
wearing fashion nova no you'll see he
goes fashion of a jacket on he's got a
he's got designer clothes he's got a
vape shorts yeah he slides
well you can tell that shirt is dog [ __ ]
compared to the other clothes yeah for
sure
and wrinkled it is and [ __ ] i pray to
god that this is their 15th minute
i don't know they might have they might
have 30 minutes of fame maybe an hour
this is the last i want to see the
island boys they're actually super big
on tick tock like they're i don't know
if you guys seen them on tick tock they
get like a lot of views on tick tock and
has
there been any developments beyond just
doing the island boy song no shitty
person
no one hit wonder interesting yeah one
head wonders
okay well anyway let me watch this again
this this is good [ __ ] yeah
oh my island but i'm a fashionable boy
oh i'm a fashion novel man let it go
fashion no
boy but i really stopped bone playing we
got fresh no more dream better taking on
the jacket and tease
[Music]
how much they get paid for this [ __ ]
probably only like a few thousand bucks
really yeah probably yeah oh damn i
don't think fashion nova i don't think
so
when it comes to the comments or just
the comment i want to [ __ ] i want the
fight
no rhyme boys why does that boy sound
like they never are gonna give you up oh
yeah it's the same melody
never gonna get oh my god it's the same
melody never gonna give you i'm never
gonna not
whoa
no wonder it went so viral i mean people
love that song
okay how long are we gonna do this
yo you guys sold out to fashion nova man
where's your artistic integrity yeah
damn
how long are we going to do this
yeah fashion nova i heard they're about
to sponsor uh o.j simpson
that'll be a good one up and coming
creator yeah r kelly actually i heard
they're working on finalizing yeah he's
got plenty of songs to get parody for
him you know
true i'm trapped in the closet full of
trapped people
that's so funny i'm hiding in the
fashion nova clothes do you have your
credit cards
hmm
did you get your shorts yeah
um this is one other one you know
we've been talking on the show about how
logan paul's life is falling apart how
he was first of all talking about how he
was he he said he takes um
opiates opiates it helps him stay
focused he was he was spinning it like
it helps me stay focused which i was
like oh boy that's
that's the beginning of a downworld
spiral too
we need to be doing that
we're we've been manifesting a lot of
things in logan's life because [ __ ]
mike [ __ ] his gym shorts that's right
that is right we
we are one well i don't wish addiction
or anything like that oh yeah that's
right let's be careful with this this is
actually really interesting because i
feel like he's doing a legitimate
uh call for help and his friends are
just [ __ ] laughing in his face yeah
it's true um i'll just say it
i'm falling apart
from the inside out i know on the
outside it looks like uh all is well and
dandy
no it's not oh it doesn't tell you you
just have to save my eyes are starting
to mirror my outside my insides are
starting to mirror my eyes mike is such
a douche he doesn't seem like a good
friend at all and mike's sober too isn't
he like yeah you know well this whole
thing is like his whole shtick is that
he's like an addiction special right
he's in recovery and everything and yeah
you [ __ ] idiot where will we be
without men and opioids
and benzos
[Laughter]
these finally catching up the gradual
collapse you've been witnessing
um
from the outside has now
ruptured my enzymes there's no spleen am
i made
i can't believe i'm saying this
in puerto rico my maid
my my puerto rican assistant uh my
puerto rican driver
my accountants back in america and
my assistant danny my beloved danny for
three and a half years of work together
are all
leaving at the same
[ __ ] time they did a huddle i swear
to god come in team
come on in
come on in hey
[ __ ] this guy am i right yeah that i
mean that just tells me that he is just
such a horrible dude to work with
that they're all like
because especially in puerto rico it's
got to be a good job to work for like
someone like logan paul i mean while
paying you would assume right
i mean i don't know but perhaps but like
um
that just tells me that he really is
[ __ ]
yeah it's true i can't help but feel
kind of bad for him in this club exactly
i will say that he doesn't when he's
surrounded by such horrible friends
right they're just like laughing
as joking as i'm being
we're we're
running as sharp and as optimized
mentally as we ever have so like
everyone we do hire needs to be a
[ __ ] kid you're really gonna go with
that
everybody needs to be he's saying
everyone we hired and still can't be
able to handle my mood swings and me
being a total [ __ ] douche to them all
the time
and being accessory to a bunch of uh
crime
yeah fraud and also probably buying him
drugs right he pays him a dink doink
yeah
dick he does ping pong's the currency of
the future dude trust me right right and
sharpen his optimized mentally as we
have ever hey man look at us are you
[ __ ] what with this guy what does he
even do like
i don't know he literally does okay do
you really want to roll with that
sentence in real life hey i can't wait
you didn't want to think that one
through for a hot second you're a
[ __ ] mess
[Music]
[ __ ]
dude what the [ __ ] did you just say
it's like how do you say that with a
straight face what are you talking about
the these are our conversations
you wouldn't think say that
i will say though
as joking as i'm being
where
we're never in one place even for more
than three days at a time yeah i mean i
mean dude it's disgusting listen i could
i can relate listen to his voice i've
been i was sick bro i can relate in a
major way i'm starting to feel the melt
of what we've done for the past year i i
highly and heavily believe that we are
we have put on more miles than any other
creators this entire year doesn't they
don't they do like one podcast away
well but now he's living in puerto rico
and is he talking about like travel yeah
traveling around what does mike do ben's
well he's got us he's got a
scam business in l.a run he's got a scam
business you got a content house with
face right constantly changing his pants
i mean yeah
all the time
all the time
carousel check on the shack right
in terms of airlines and flying to
create content we have been all around
the world
every single day i haven't spent more
than two days in la at the house at a
time in so long and i'm starting to feel
that [ __ ] burnout bad bro well lucky
for you mike it's the end of the year
and i know because what because you can
also start to feel the world slowing
down i can feel it now like it's that
it's that q4
that everyone's like dude i've been
working all year like bro if you're
watching and listening to this i know
you feel it you're like christmas is
coming dude thanksgiving is here you
feel that great
dinner table with a [ __ ] fat turkey
we're never yeah anyway i feel the the
desperate call for help
this clip's going to be in the logan
paul documentary in five years
yeah
where he's got it downhill i would say
to logan paul someone who's been there
myself
not with the know drug addiction
but or the scamming or the scamming yeah
you know
or the boxing
or the body
but the burnout yes yeah the mental
anguish yes
he's like you got to take a step back
bro you got to take some time off you
got to get some therapy you got to get
off the opiates and on to the
antidepressants
you know what i'm saying
talk to a psychiatrist talk to a
therapist take some time off
regroup you know
get yourself centered get yourself to a
good place before you come back the
answer is not to double down on work and
also maybe get some new friends yeah you
should surround yourself with supportive
friends absolutely get away from the
goons dude
yeah um you know mike the addiction
specialist over here
such a douche
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] is gym shorts yeah i
mean what this what more i love that we
can say that unironically yeah [ __ ] his
gym shorts uh it's interesting though
you know i didn't i for some reason i
didn't see drug addiction uh being on my
logan paul bingo card i will say that's
definitely what's happening
it's sad it's yeah
i mean yeah
apparently he's planning on fighting
mike tyson
tyson like 60. he yeah he's old as [ __ ]
i mean i know it's mike tyson but
mike tyson age
um he is 55 okay that's not too bad
i mean i'd watch it iron mike baby
mike tyson so you know oh hello
i want to make it sound like i'm like oh
i actually heard jake paul is fighting
muhammad ali wow
that's impressive you're digging them up
and you're just gonna mm-hmm
he's still alive right no no oh [ __ ]
god was the joke you were making well no
because he was in a wheelchair he had
parked yeah but he's also dead
i think it's funnier he's alive with
parkinson's
dead yeah they got like a body of the
wrath like pop it you know like although
then that seems like more of a logan
matchup right well no jake's the one
that always fights like the
people that never had a chance to beat
him right logan has a history with them
those who are no longer of the earth
though right that's true he like yeah he
likes to interact with cadavers that was
cool
so this so he died huh [ __ ] me a few
years back 2016. he was back yeah then
he was holding in there he was hanging
in there keeping it ripped
ripped to the goat my dude recently must
be doing well i haven't heard much about
him
oh just by the way speaking of kavanaugh
i'm on wikipedia now so on huh oh boy
ryan kavanaugh's page
has been an absolute [ __ ]
battleground dude
since our last one
first they put a disclaimer
multiple issues it may have been created
or edited and returned for undisclosed
payments hmm i wonder
i wonder what that means
and then so basically they were
they removed the controversies part
but what they did instead is they added
to his career section
that uh
let's see
the um
relativity media
see there's some new [ __ ] in here uh
following their bankruptcy rka film
financing
one of the lenders sued the company for
miss spending its marketing fund and
called kavanaugh a con man see that's
new info someone got in there yeah
yeah that's funny i i definitely would
consider him a con man based on what
i've seen looks like it's got some
citation too so you know it's legit oh
yeah countersued for 200 million
the next paragraph's interesting he
stepped down and then yeah so the next
one it talks about
how he um rank kavanaugh defrauded
uh this dude carrie metz
into making a 10 million investment
relativity media
uh awesome
and then it went on and then also they
mentioned this is my favorite cav cav uh
fact
that in 2008
arbitration case founded 18 found that
uh
an
at relativity of media including
kavanaugh had fabricated a memo alleging
sexual harassment
against former co-president and it even
goes on to say
that the memo had been altered by a user
named kav now this is good this is
important stuff people should know this
is his legacy absolutely
you know
um he stated that it was patently false
okay well whatever you say cav
cav and it continues on damn he was sued
by ex-partner elon spar for fraud how
many times this guy been sued for fraud
sounds like a lot maybe
like
a lot yeah more than this guy does more
fraud than logan and mike combined true
and jaw rule john you throw a jaw roll
you throw adam ross you throw them all
in there man i get the feeling that this
won't be the last time too just the
feeling that with his recent actions you
know well there is seems to be a pattern
right yeah
uh he was sued by his ex-partner elon
sparr
[Music]
um oh look at the last little bit oh
outline oh this one says something about
a ponzi scheme so that's good he didn't
have a sentence before films produce
that's new
in 2019 kevin along with business
partner bobby
same vest of proxima media acquired a
majority stake in trailer
coinciding with the trump
administration's uh announcement
to ban tick talk yeah it's the next one
that's interesting
uh in november that's this year or this
this month
along with trill and others was named in
a lawsuit over unauthorized and unlawful
use of patent symbol oh that's what we
talked about the try thing
yo so this this is important stuff this
is your legacy ryan
and apparently also
there's so much going back and forth
with uh
ryan dude i'm telling this story's so
interesting we'll get into it on friday
but apparent i mean allegedly based on
what we've seen on the back end this
this is
a speculation but he has like a army of
sock puppets that they've traced back to
his ip banned all the sock puppets
and um he's arguing with them he's
bitching about how
uh they erased all of his uh
he had like this huge uh philanthropy
section
and they erased a bunch of it as
unsighted and [ __ ] and he's like what
the [ __ ] you're racing my history
and apparently
allegedly uh speculatively
right he was editing my wikipedia page
from one of his sock puppets oh my gosh
yes he was [ __ ]
like that
he put he added uh he was putting my
controversies
on my wikipedia page as one of his sock
puppets that was banned is that right he
was specifically he put
uh ethan klein is currently
in
uh the process of falsely editing ryan
kavanaugh's wikipedia page he put that
on your wikipedia page like as if by the
way first of all as if that's even like
a meaningful edit to my wikipedia
like how can you even compare that to
peop editors of wikipedia right writing
this is your legacy bro this is who you
are
um and then if you go down to personal
life they also added a section legal
problems where they talk about his duis
they
so this is actually really interesting i
need to look up the strides end effect
for real because like this is all a
result
oh like he could just be floating along
with triller right now you know having a
good old time having a good old time
throwing totally well what the failed
event what's interesting is that
actually the wikipedia editors who are
like these were researchers these people
live for citation and facts they added
[ __ ] in here that i never even heard of
like yeah
the legal problem's really interesting
2006 kavanaugh was arrested after
driving under the influence of alcohol
we knew that and involved in a hit and
run incident yeah cool after all but the
dui charge which was less into wet and
reckless chart that sounds kind of fun
wet and reckless
if you want to know what being [ __ ]
privileged is this is what it is he was
involved in a dui
[ __ ] hit and run
and he it was reduced l charges were
dropped and it was loose uh reduced to
wet and reckless
like i'm sorry bro but you definitely
know that judge allegedly with peace and
love yeah or his daddy did
kavanaugh was ordered to pay one
thousand four hundred dollars take
counseling and alcohol education
programs and was placed on 36 months of
probation
in which she was required to drive sober
uh
obviously
for the next 36 months no drunk driving
ryan
no but in his case when you're rich in
white it's called uh wet and reckless
which is
crazy
that's crazy well continues so in 2008
two years later kavanaugh was arrested
again for speeding and drunk driving
with a suspended license now that to me
sounds like a serious [ __ ] crime you
already got busted once for drunk
driving you're on three years probation
two years later he's still on probation
and he and drunk he's speeding and drunk
with a suspended license from his
previous dui kavanaugh pleaded guilty to
violating his probation and now uses a
driver
all other charges were dropped what the
[ __ ] this guy should be in jail for that
yeah like that's a serious [ __ ] crime
that's that's yeah but this guy's such a
degenerate alcoholic that he has a
driver now
awesome i mean the danger he put people
in doing that is just insane but it's
his second offense while on probation
with a [ __ ] he this that's jail bro
yeah that'd be so selfish to drunk drive
yeah yeah
that's just like
okay sorry that's defamation it's called
wet and reckless yeah right my bad i
think i take it back all charges were
dropped it was already hit and run too
so you know like that could have been
that could have been a person too you
know like like but he's just well when
you know the judge when you're friends
with the judge that hit-and-run turns
into wet and reckless
and then they also got here in 2020
babysitter of newborn child fought a
lawsuit for breach of contract
uh seeking 175 000 in damages so then
they got in they got details about this
i didn't know
although the 13-month employment was
originally agreed to kavanaugh abruptly
filed
fired the babysitter
uh due to child custody issues so it
sounds like he lost custody or he had
split custody with his kid and then he's
like well [ __ ] you i don't need you
anymore even though i signed a contract
with you which is it seems like that's
how he treats a lot of his employees
based on that one person that called and
talked to av
but on the good news he was named by
variety as 2011 showman of the year
so shout outs so i would say that ryan
kavanaugh's wikipedia page is now
a accurate reflection of his legacy and
who he is so absolutely and stuff very
informative
all right we are uh all right so so um
anyway let's throw it to a break let's
thank our sponsors and then let's get
into the main segment of today the
thanksgiving you laugh you die
thank you thank you to
blenders i wear from the san diego
california comes the only sunglass brand
i'm ever going to wear again i'm talking
about blenders eyewear and you're going
to be
just as hooked when you see how awesome
these shades are check this out
blender's eyewear you got the big ass
mingo
the run go let's go i mean yeah this
they got everything gifts for her i
guess for him let's look at glasses for
myself here
can i cruise in these i mean i know this
for like snowing but can i just cruise
in these i mean you could i could pull
it off you got a wild style yeah these
are these are sick beautiful you know
love them
gorgeous here's the deal
okay
chase fisher started blenders by selling
his beachy shades out of a backpack
while doubling as a serpent structure on
pacific beach his goal was to create an
adventurous mid-priced eyewear option
with the same cool factors other lead
styles and unlike
expensive big brand shades you're
probably
lost or smashed into pieces blenders are
actually affordable you're not going to
cry as much when you know the inevitable
happens blender's team of in-house
designers are constantly coming out with
new styles from orange polarized
wrap-arounds
tortoise shell frames with purple lenses
to classic gold arms on black lenses and
it's not just sunglasses blenders are
prescription glasses readers and blue
light as well as snow collections with
goggles and accessories
live life and forward motion with
blenders today to score 15
off your blender's purchase visit
blenderseyeware.com
and enter the promo code h3 vip
that's
blenderseyeware.com code h3 vip for 15
off blenders rock with pride worldwide
hbo max has kept my streaming queued up
stocked all year with all kinds of
amazing content but one thing i'm
officially especially excited about
is all these amazing things that keep
coming down the pipeline you know dune
by the way the dune movies on hbo max i
freaking first of all that movie
is amazing i cannot believe you get to
watch that for free
on hbo
max streaming it's just it's like too
good to be true i liked it so much i
started reading the books i already read
the first two books i'm on the third
book now uh i definitely recommend dune
hbo max is basically turned into my
favorite streaming platform they've got
the many saints of new work that's the
um
sopranos sopranos prequel secession i
know a lot of people love that insecure
the new curb your enthusiasm is out
there's so much great options on hbo max
i absolutely
love hbo max i cannot recommend it
enough hbo max has all your favorite
titles available for streaming they got
something for everyone with everything
you love all in one place plus you can
download top titles to watch on your
device to go so don't miss out on taking
your entertainment game to the next
level hbo max's streaming
home
of over 13 000 hours of addictive series
blockbuster movies an exclusive original
start streaming on your favorite device
today sign up now at hbom
dot a x slash h3 rails these guys come
up with the wildest urls bro hbo m.a.x
what is that i never even heard of the
ax
domain i think they invented it just so
they could get clever with this have
their name
that's hbo
m.a.f
h3 rails don't worry the link's in the
description anyway guys dude trust me
you're not going to regret hbo max i
freaking love it
listen thank you honey we love honey we
all shop online and we've seen that
promo code field taunt us at checkout
but thank you to honey manually
searching for coupon codes it's a thing
of the past honey is the free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one it finds
at your cart
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
ranging from tech gaming products to
fashion brands and even food delivery
um imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites and when you check
out the honey button drop sound and all
you have to do is click apply coupon
wait a few seconds that honey as honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site and voila if honey finds a
working coupon magically watch the price
drop here's one that ela saved she was
doing some shopping around the house
you know five bucks 40 cents but that's
money we wouldn't wouldn't even dream of
saving before i mean
it's like every time i buy something
online
i'm saving money
because i'm not spending my time looking
for coupons anymore especially now that
i've got honey installed
it really is magic you know it's free
you don't have to think about it dude
you don't even have to think about it
it's it's just it's one of the best
things ever uh if you don't have honey
you're really missing out
um honey has found its 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings if you don't already have honey
you could be straight up missing out on
free savings it's literally free
installs in a few seconds and by getting
it you're going to be helping us out
and you're going to be doing yourself a
solid
i use it all the time guys and i
recommend it a lot so get honey for free
at joinhoney.com h3 that's joinhoney.com
h3 thank you thank you to honey
well welcome everybody this is i guess
um
a tradition now
you laugh you die
challenge
um it's thanksgiving we all want to get
together and share the holiday
we started this tradition a few years
ago with the you laugh you lose where we
had pumpkin pie made of mayo you had to
take a bite
if you
laughed
you know
last year i kind of embarrassed myself i
have to say i got goofed on because i
talked to big game my video sucked and i
laughed at everything well this year
i've been in training
and i am not gonna [ __ ] laugh and i'm
not eating any of that [ __ ] that sam
made
[Laughter]
yeah so this year we made or well sam
made i'm not gonna take credit for that
abominations yeah
yeah so sam made uh six traditional
thanksgiving meals with a small twist in
them and each person will take a turn
sharing videos trying to make the other
participants at the table laugh
if you laugh you have to eat the dish
for the round
before you guys get angry at me the
ian's not at the table people blame me
ian is switching
yes
yes
we miss you is there any way we can get
you to take a bite of any of this [ __ ]
no can we include ian in any way i'm
cool on sitting this one out i think
maybe he has to try all of them oh i
feel like he's i don't think he's
dodging bro
the chef's not going to try his food
yeah what kind of chef doesn't taste
their own
switch
that's what i'm saying like he he you
know there's plenty of people that know
how to switch in this office
i know i give you the credit you're very
good at it though uh
last night when sam finished cooking
this we didn't have enough room in our
fridge so i had to drive it down here to
the office early and on the way i i was
like
do i have to pull over because i thought
the car was like breaking down and it
was just the stink of the food but it
sounded like burning gasoline oh wow
what which one was that it smelled so
bad you thought it was
burning
electronics yeah i thought i was gonna
have to pull over great
sounds like cancer causing possibly some
of that
right now i actually i don't mind the
smell i can't believe i think it smells
nice it smells thanksgivingy
yeah like a small rodent crawled up in
the radiator or something no it smells
totally fine it's like blown out candles
but yeah mix of flavors do you guys
think it smells better that is horrible
right now yes so um how's everyone
feeling today how thanksgiving plans
anyone uh
uh i have a flight after this hopefully
i don't miss it
we'll make sure you're on time
also you came in here like kind of like
stunting on us all like what's going on
here i'm just i'm just going straight to
thanksgiving dinner with this um yeah
what i said what is it i'm like you h m
looking [ __ ] and you're like oh
it's express express wait let's express
it's like a douchier h m i feel like is
it pricier than h m yeah low premium
what this is like between h m and zara
what'd this run you uh this was 200 on
black friday oh years ago good bro
damn let me see let me see this [ __ ]
exactly inside a little nice lining wow
damn what's up why is [ __ ] pocket square
no it's a little pocket okay wait you
don't have a pocket square no
unfortunately on your inner pocket
lame
well you're going you're go having it
tonight thanksgiving dinner no no i'm
gonna get there at 1am this just didn't
fit my suitcase so you made it sound
like you're going straight from the
airplane to thanksgiving dinner but
that's not what that's not what's
happening no this is just a heavy jacket
and
trying to preserve room in this suitcase
sleep in the blazer
yeah
any other interesting plants for
thanksgiving no mine just got cancelled
because somebody in my family uh has a
coveted scare so
it's like kind of dope though when
thanksgiving gets cancelled because
you're like
you know what
i like
i like what i do
okay with it yeah yeah you know we're
rescheduling it though i mean as long as
they're okay we're doing yeah no that
they're not they haven't tested positive
or anything
somebody that they were in contact with
yeah
yeah
what about you cam what are you doing uh
i'm fortunate enough to have some
buddies in town or do you want to oh no
so i'm going to do a friend's friend's
giving type thing oh great and also i
love the family's merch that's authentic
right oh yeah one of one very rare
uh but yeah totally legit dude
sick super authentic
zacky i'm sure having a good time having
some brisket yeah i requested like i
said no turkey this year yeah i'm like i
want a big ass [ __ ] ribeye steak and
i'm getting it
damn who's buying it uh family my i'm
going down to my grandmother's and
you're like grandma i need a big ass
ribeye i'm like i'm 24 i've done enough
[ __ ] thanksgivings i want steak
so is anyone else eating turkey yeah my
whole my whole family and you just told
say grandma you need to buy my ass to
stay yeah jesus a little bit of a prima
donna
i mean table what do you have your own
table like in the corner it's the cool
kids table yeah the cool kids table so
you're going to be the only guy at this
place eating a steak yeah and everyone
else is eating turkey yeah nice i'm
looking forward to the price uh a little
minute
yeah
easy bake oven actually
are you allowed to eat any of the other
thanksgiving food
i mean i guess if i want i i don't i
would i would prohibit it if i was your
grandmother i'd be like listen [ __ ]
you want the steak you can't have
anything like this or anything else she
she knows i hate turkey so i mean she
was very accommodating about it oh you
hate turkey i do [ __ ] hate turkey
i feel like that's a common sentiment
it's overrated i mean there's a reason
we only eat it once a year
also if you've got family like mine that
don't really cook it's just you're dry
it's just yeah
you know some people get weird with it
they like
deep fry a whole damn turkey in like a
garbage can and that's interesting my
family's not they don't really get down
with anything interesting like that
what about you two are you olivia
my family doesn't really cook i think
whole foods will be catering oh for real
let's go it's a good route
i think so too
they won't cook anything
it won't be good
if they do like my mom sometimes tries
but she knows
damn so you guys
pick up like a costco a costco chicken
no whole foods does a like a good
thanksgiving
thanksgiving oh special i bet you that's
pretty good it is every year that shit's
not cheap either i don't think
i don't think it's super cheap well
either it's buying
yeah it's a super expensive holiday it's
a whole damn animal yeah yeah
that it is a whole damn animal well
although chicken lives don't matter
apparently because you can buy them at
costco for five bucks yeah it's at 4.99
they matter
sorry is that matter to me they mattered
to me damn it
little chickies what have uh you got
going on tomorrow love
um well
over here um since you guys teach me
that uh thanksgiving is a racist holiday
i will not be celebrating good you know
woking
[Applause]
well there you go i'm taking a hard
stance against it okay good for you he's
way more are you gonna have any fika or
you anti-freaking
[Laughter]
oh
well i'm glad to hear your conscientious
objector that's very good otherwise i'm
sure you would be having a huge
thanksgiving meal oh for sure for
american thanksgiving absolutely yeah
all right well with all that being said
i'm hungry personally
so let's just get this party started huh
so before we get into it we should
introduce the dish right
okay so i'll be going first sam so let's
show me show me make it a bad one
because i guess whoever presents doesn't
have to eat so make it a real [ __ ] up
one two of them have meat which makes me
very like grossed out and nervous
so i believe this one she's bringing out
is a classic
just
it eroded from from the fumes that looks
a little metal gun
it's a classic stuffing is the metal
spit supposed to be in it
just like screws rusted screws
so what do we got here uh ian this is a
classic it's uh
thanksgiving stuffing can't go wrong
it looks a little thick to me
it looks like it doesn't look that
classic cut like a dessert yeah like it
looks like peanut brittle or something
something here right here what's with
the white chunks like they're supposed
like it looks like marshmallows but oh
wait a minute i have a feeling i know
what those chunks are garlic
yeah full garlic cloves not going on a
plane after eating
that doesn't look bad
i don't mind garlic are they coming out
garlic
oh it's cooked garlic ain't nothing
wrong with that
yum pickled garlic i'm gonna piss off
the discord they're always debating
about garlic for some reason
there's nothing wrong with garlic yeah i
mean i love garlic it looks great i get
the feeling though it's not just garlic
that's cursed in here though let me take
a sniff the garlic and the uh
there might be some yeah oh yeah those
are full chunks of garlic
it smells like peanut butter
stop it actually smells it doesn't smell
that bad i'll be honest with you guys
okay i'm sure it doesn't taste good but
maybe we'll enjoy it then
it's don't smell give it a give us give
that a nice sniff tell me what you think
don't don't do it like that it's not
that if he throws up this episode i quit
i don't know it's not that bad
i'm gonna take a bite of that it's
okay yeah
it's not that bad but it's not this i
mean it's off
something off about that
i like the peanut butter kinda
yeah it's not bad yeah no it's not bad
will uh we'll
unveil the ingredients after someone
tries it okay got it oh good or do it
after that smells good exactly
okay all right well we'll see being a
little bit of a drama queen when it
comes to garlic definitely
dude aren't you like you're aren't you
like [ __ ] middle eastern it's all
about garlic over there
well okay whatever let's get started
yeah let's see what we got all right so
i so i will be sharing today my friends
videos to make y'all laugh
all right so this one is
about three minutes long so obviously
just stick with it okay and and and then
ian are you gonna be watching these guys
like hawks to make sure nobody laugh oh
yeah okay and sam you're watching too
okay good so and then love you also have
eyes on it
yes sir and can i can laugh if i'm
showing it yeah that'll that'll hurt
your guys's chances that's true all
right so this one is called help me
janus okay
just keep your heads all the way back
okay
snortles through his nose a little bit
there i'll give you a pass
keep your head back
feet on the ground
cam is breaking
stacked out
[Music]
it's so good how she like doesn't care
that he's he's like dying hung i said
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
i hate her she's like an evil [ __ ]
so normally that would have made me
laugh for sure but oh i was able to just
kind of focus i was able to focus my
mind on how [ __ ] up that actually is
yeah yeah
and i was able to read this you left
yeah i did so you three go ahead bottoms
up let's go see what we got that's only
the first toy ladies first there you go
help me janice i'm bringing some goods
that was great none of you guys have
ever seen that one before i i've seen
similar ones i have not seen that one
i think you've got to get a garlic you
hit the garlic that's a big-ass bite
though i don't think you need to eat
that yeah thank you so much could i get
a plate
no no cam no hand bearing baby i will
require all right go ahead um
thank you
go ahead
do we use the salad or go all right
bottoms up same time everybody uh olivia
go for it we'll go for it yeah
so let's see olivia
[Music]
is chewing it up
she said it smell good so it's like
good flavor profiles
separately
and my mouth is having a really hard
time
i'm gonna go in for it
[Laughter]
zach likes it eh
let's not forget the last time we did
this on silent oh are you struggling
i'm getting flashbacks to the muddy
huddy a little bit yeah i was just
saying
the last time we did this zach was talk
would go in he was talking such a big
game and when we finished he was like
sick he was like out of commission yeah
it was awful it's just sitting in my
mouth
it's hard to true i can't you can spit
it out
in this
there's a trash can
all right i don't do a good start right
now
spitting it out you can do it you can do
it you can do it bite bro
i cannot take the garlic oh come on what
are we doing here oh man all right well
i'll give it a bite well here there's i
see a smaller piece of garlic on the
other piece on the bottom yeah is that
your compromise yeah as long as you're
getting some garlic yeah you've got to
get some garlic you can do it i believe
in you the peanut butter
was good okay i could have i could have
eaten that peanut butter you just fit it
out you're already here
it was the whole garlic though the head
came out
all of it
cam is uh i think grimacing a little bit
chewing slowly you can do it
olivia has ejected the food out of her
mouth zack swallowed it dude yeah it's
just weird it's like not bad but it's
just weird oh not bad there you go okay
are you gonna swallow it are you able to
swallow it i have to but there you go
good job guys what up and shout out to
janice
[Applause]
we're bringing three of you down because
i still have more videos that was like
mental warfare
i really really wanted to laugh i had to
just focus on how sad i was for the kid
the way you guys did it last time was
every time someone laughed there was a
tally and then whoever had the most
tallies
at the end right
yeah so each video we eat
yeah oh boy those are the worst rules
who changed it wait are we keeping a
tally
it's somewhere we can yeah we should
okay because i i don't want to lose
again this year all right i'll uh i'll
i'll start telling maybe ink or sam can
keep it out or you can do it dan a few
that's fine yeah all right so that was
help me janice
you gotta eat that other piece dude
no you i think that was sufficient oh
you don't no you don't
don't want it don't listen to him you
want it
all right next up might have to eat a
bunch more people everyone ready for the
second video
let's do it
okay here we go guys this is an old
standard but one that i live by
you ready dan god i know this one yeah
okay here we go
video number two
said no boomer names yeah
there's a contest to stump and how are
you measuring who does the best dumping
and whoever stomps the most shoes wins
an overnight stay but it's not the only
thing you can do the measuring cups are
down below right measuring cups are down
below all right so and and if you if you
win you get to stay a chat to my lawn
and what else do you have going on sam
is laser focused
nobody's hitting by
eating international food having wine
tours and tastings in your tours
seminars
[Laughter]
oh come on you exhale from your nose the
count i don't know does it
dance
oh dear if i'm already if i'm already
[ __ ] dinner oh my gosh i hope she's
okay
okay it doesn't sound like this this has
always been my favorite part is the is
the anchor oh no oh no she does not
sound okay
you're doing this replaying [ __ ] yes
i think
oh no we had a hard and fast roll one
replay only
only that's fair because last time ethan
would spam it over and over again until
people started laughing no replays we
could do no replays or no replays maybe
one like one just like re-examine this
one part
sometimes the replay is the funnier one
so yeah so i mean i got it i got it was
that the only one dan excelled from his
nose fantastic dirty dan i'm not yours
he's dirty i'm not gonna eat it
all right dan is going for a nice
generous bite proud of him for that nice
big well
it's a big-ass garlic and that's fine
i'm happy with that i mean i get all the
yeah components there right yeah i'm
happy with that
going in for a nice bite of classic
stuffing
you want to describe it
grimacing not loving the experience i
can hear him chew he's he's really he's
are you ready to abort
dan looks like he's about to yeah he's
just like me i just held it in my mouth
wait so he's holding it in his mouth
he's not loving it
he's going
oh
you want to describe that
that was pretty horrific you guys were
downplaying that big time
what i mean
well you got the most amount of garlic
yeah a few so
i think that's the i think you're right
it without the garlic
it's a little weird but it's actually
kind of an interesting dish yeah i'm a
fan of the peanut butter stuffing
but the the garlic is is the wild card
there and that all right well done dan
thank you i think this next one's gonna
get some of you guys it's a two-parter
okay
just get ready everybody
everybody get ready for this okay
also i'll uh start i'll start taking uh
tally dan okay you don't have to worry
about it what the [ __ ] ethan
all right zach you're already laughing
just get be serious now
everyone ready
this is this should be against the rules
it is
i'm the [ __ ] boss what role
what was that well i wasn't laughing at
the video as well okay that was like a
george bush laugh it was enough
oh my god
okay this on her channel yes yes
hari krishna yoga meditation extended
version
okay so that's part one okay i'm just
softening you guys up for part two get
ready watch closely sam
this is also on her channel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i almost broke when i noticed the
dislikes it wasn't even the video itself
oh they didn't that's funny they didn't
remove the dislike
for everyone but trisha's meditation
videos see i feel like i was tough but i
i someone said where's the tomato option
if you threw in that video i would have
broke
you said if i led with that one no no no
the one the tomato one the tick tock
live i have part three
and now you you said two parts yeah you
can't you can't improvise like that okay
well done you guys were just scared of
the consequence now i'm the only one
that looks like an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you guys knew that i wanted to laugh i
wanted to harry harvey i was very close
i was i was just thinking about that
garlic again
all right this one is a little bit
longer but
it's a journey
i if you let's just let's just do a
little experiment here okay all right
guys
oh my god
thumbnail
i have seen this
but i've seen a shorter kickback version
[Music]
new york
these are the type of videos you find
when you first start smoking you look up
like trippy videos
you know these weird animations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a crazy huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm mostly trying not to laugh thinking
about how you find this really funny
well that's the funniest part to me
really you just because this is just
trippy and like
and like kind of beautiful too well it's
shocking and surprising and
except i mean i have the advantage of
having seen it before i suppose it's a
very tool
okay
right just kind of things yeah yeah i
appreciate the yeah the variation and
approach if there wasn't garlic in that
plate i probably would have laughed
yeah and you're just hyper focused on
that garlic focus
quick tip if you ever find yourself
zach king we don't need your magic vine
compilation
zach king is very talented though i do
like zack king shadow exactly
okay this is my favorite one
okay this is one i don't know if i've
shared with you guys i i recovered it in
my memory
so there's this game heavy rain
and there's a glitch
so you push a button to say stuff and
and
the button makes you scream sean which i
guess is his son
but there's a glitch where you can keep
pushing the x button and he keeps
screaming sean throughout this cut scene
okay
but you can't be laughing he's already
laughing this is one i love this video
okay here we go it's gonna be rough god
damn okay guys no laughing now you're
laughing already dan all right here we
go
i was watched
i was laughing yes i was watching this
yesterday and i was like gasping for
breath laughing so hard
i hope it's not too late
zack's out dan's out
also what's funny about the bug is that
his mouth always moves
[Music]
[Music]
like the character always move his mouth
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i know who the killer is ethan
[Laughter]
you're about to break congratulations
ethan
[Music]
you succeeded
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm afraid that's not possible
[Music]
i'm going to have to kill you
i'm sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
also what's amazing is as she gets
further away
his voice gets more faint
wait he's back
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my god you know what um oh wow all
right there was a a version the original
version was some dude recording a screen
and they cut some about where it's
really far away from the action you
could just barely
okay i'm bringing the heat today my boys
that was that was great the end of the
so
dan cam
zach and olivia abe is flawless
victory so far
there you have it oh man the second one
was worse it was way worse
besides peanut butter and garlic yeah so
we can reveal the uh
ingredients now ian
uh okay so this is listed as uh
stuffing mix
garlic reese's pieces and espresso
oh a little coffee interesting
that's very creative it's like not gross
stuff but together yeah kind of gross
horrific conversation so yeah espresso
with the the reese's pieces make sense
yeah it's like sweet it must have been
the [ __ ] hairs all right so up next
we have uh
dan oh you want to go
what do you think dan i'm going next
baby okay so um
sam if you will this will be the
punishment for my videos here
thank you for leaving your gum thank you
so much um awful
yeah well thank you appreciate that you
got it all right so what we have here
appears to be a um
casserole
green bean casserole that's right
is there meat on this thing
there is meat in it yes
okay so we've got green beans some
cheese
i mean if you didn't if you if i didn't
know better i just think that was a
yummy looking uh green bean casserole
nice and creamy right kim there's
definitely mayonnaise a little crispies
sniff
simply mayo in there oh boy oh i hate
that idea
anyone else want to hit it yeah
i don't know just
that seems worse than the last one
smells like dog food
there's a [ __ ] bug on there no no no
it's a fly oh it's just it's alive it's
a living bug is that part of the dish no
i don't know i don't
that one is just i don't know the
creaminess is not i'm not a fan of the
blood i'm missing out on this one it
smells like a bowl of grape nuts
oh [ __ ] the live bug
yeah you're right i think that yeah
those are great
oh how'd you call that that's so
interesting i used to eat grape nuts a
lot i i always
i questioned it who would eat grape nuts
it's like ian is one of those ian and i
are like the only people i think i have
no idea what that is grape nuts is like
matrix gruel it's like it's really good
[ __ ] sand i don't know who can eat
that [ __ ]
it is it's so funny oh
you're you're right you're right it is
all right are we ready i'm ready all
right here's my first video
it's happened again another sign
language interpreter accused of signing
total gibberish this time it was at the
police news conference announcing an
arrest in the tampa serial killings we
will be charging
four counts
first agreement
standing off to the side apparently
translating every word
but it turns out much of what she was
signing was nonsense she waved her arms
around like she was singing jingle bells
says one outraged sign language expert
the woman identified as durlin roberts
has a string of arrests for fraud so how
did she come to be translating at last
week's high-profile police news
conference i just didn't ask enough
questions tampa police public
information officers that's a bad
quality for a cop the woman simply
showed up out of the blue and offered
her services
my immediate reaction was i didn't call
for a sign language interpreter but
that's great that we have one here i let
her in did this woman appear to know
what she was doing to the untrained eye
and that would include mine
i didn't see any problems this latest
embarrassment comes three months after
it was revealed that the sign language
interpreter at her hurricane irma news
conference also in florida made no sense
the time to act is now look at his hand
motions summing up the latest goof we
won't be using that woman again
cops say this was not a crime but it was
an ethical violation
[Music]
oh not a crime
it's not a crime
did anyone laugh no i don't think so i
thought it was great
yeah i loved that video i was being
strong but apparently nobody well i knew
i knew it was probably because the part
that always gets me is the guy saying um
i just didn't ask enough questions
can i can i make a a comment about
chairs in general
okay i can't be the only one that when
you sit down your shirt rides up and it
shows your axe crack um potentially you
worry about that why the [ __ ] do chairs
always have
officials like a visual spot for your
ass crack it's [ __ ] insane close the
gap people and i have to feel the chair
and i go yep there's an ass crack spot
close the [ __ ] gap you don't need ass
correct windows client 2021 close the
gap
i'm talking saw gaps and synthetic
all right
you good i'm good okay
got out of the system
i don't want to eat that [ __ ] i'm going
to keep it
keep it down i'm going to go there
keep it 50 i'm gonna keep it very fast
stop it right now there's the next one
wait that's that
[Music]
we can't hear the sound we need the
sound a little bit just just for a
minute
okay stop it already is that the day you
ran over those three people yes actually
is that count i fell sorry about it oh
nice yeah i made you laugh okay momentum
that's a pretty good performing tick
tock for you right zach i mean 4500 i've
had better
okay but
i'm glad you find it funny dan thank you
now guts the gut uh
i'm not laughing i'm just smiling zach
always makes you smile
oh it makes you smile um that's very
sweet yeah that's nice
little cutie squirt all right all right
we we only got cam on that one yeah
you're a tough competitor during my
round i'm a giggler i don't know what to
tell you man giggling i i fell out the
most on him thanks for finding that
funny day well i'm doing good so far i'm
proud of myself i mean i've only done
two videos but right
i'm going for it last time i was just
taking l's at every turn
don't be shy i'm a little shy get in
there that's fine that's fine that's
annoying okay bosses hold on let me see
yeah that's fine
go more if you no no no you're good
you're good you're good that's enough
too
okay well you didn't even eat all of it
on the fork okay you're fine
so just you want to talk us through it
it's got a weird texture
um
was she right is it grape nuts i don't
know what a grape knot is yeah i mean
yeah maybe it's i think it's green beans
yeah those look like green beans um yeah
grape nuts would be the brown part it's
like a little wheat bowls yeah it's not
cheap balls it's not as bad as the last
time but still i would never order this
at a restaurant okay
good to know
cameron ladies and gentlemen there you
go
well done
all right next step all right uh no need
to mute this this is royalty free this
is checked okay all good okay
bro don't [ __ ] me with some
damn's looking straight up
is that real time
so fast what is that
yo donkeys
[Music]
yo that's like batman
[Music]
[Music]
how are those people not falling off
isn't that bad for the donkey to run on
asphalt like that more probably i think
i don't give a coke or something yeah he
just did a bun
donkey
oh i hope the donkey's okay that's made
me feel sad
damn it
[Applause]
that they probably had to execute that
donkey afterwards
i saw the full video it slows down to a
stop but you know it doesn't hurt
collapse
they run like that on asphalt they
it's like permanent damage really yeah
well that's unfortunate i don't know
exactly
i'm impressed with that donkey's speed
man
it's a warrior yeah
can you talk us through it
it smells like dog food
oh it kind of has that texture too
better not me
because i've tried dog food before have
you how does it compare interesting
purina
blue buffalo actually okay brand
yeah that's high quality
i mean i've had a better dog food but
yeah that's pretty good you got better
dog food than that food yeah interesting
blue buffalo you know they got the
salmon and stuff only the best for my
pooch yeah i mean us too
all right
shout out to the donkey king after the
donkey rest in peace to him executed
shortly after y'all watched lisa back in
the day
never heard of it
[Music]
lisa like liza oh weirdly left debbie's
son dan in a coma with only a 50 chance
of surviving now the hospital even
advised her to call the coroner but this
bleak story took a miraculous turn and
today we'll find out how one of tv's
most popular sitcoms intervened to
magically change the course of dan's
life please welcome debbie castille and
her son dan
how you doing
so i turned it on and
immediately when the tv went on it was
right at the beginning of the show with
that funny kinky wow kind of music larry
davis saves another life
and i noticed dan for the first time has
he had a very stupourous expression on
his face for the seven weeks looks like
he wished he was back at the science
flew open
he looked at the tv set
and he i was going oh my goodness maybe
it's too loud and i've startled him so i
turned it down a little but he continued
to stare at it
and
he looked at me and he whispered first
words i'd heard in seven weeks
where am i
and i thought
i thought oh here's mom
here's our favorite tv show but this
isn't home
[Music]
ever since i'm any parent it's just the
most uh gut-wrenching experience i've
gone through in my life
believe they got a miracle in their
lives uh dan was in a coma it looked
pretty grim i mean they told debbie
let's call the corner cheer up bro
you're alive watching seinfeld one night
i got a soundbite snapped out of it
whatever connected it worked why do you
think
you survived it dan
because i'm hardheaded
although he does get a little brain
damage i'm starting to fall together and
then it was the theme song
but really i just want to show the whole
thing
because he's as brain dead as i used to
be
i'm sure that'll get him out
what'd
anyone who's as big a fan as you are who
would actually come out of your coma
just not to miss a show
should have
a seinfeld cap for that hard head
are you [ __ ] me in the ass right now
this dude
[Applause]
music the music that i do seems to have
a good influence on you so here's a
little cd of something
thank
this you went through a damn coma ain't
got a hat and a tv
it's like a theme park i'll tell you
about this that was my mate the talk
shows have come a long way since then
oprah would have like
oh yeah paid all of his medical debt or
something
they're like we understand you have
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
medical bills that's unfortunate here's
a seinfeld hat
and wait check it out and a cd jonathan
wolf
yeah that was the man himself he was
there that's the baseline boy yeah
here's the color of that look and some
crap that's crazy because those guys are
so rich too
oh man it's like you're going for round
two here
likes it he doesn't even mind
we got any boo boo blue buffalo
might want to supplement it with some
dog food but michael buble michael boo
boo boo all right i'm doing good feeling
good
it's that booster shot
oh god damn it ethan you can't say
things during the video that makes me
laugh what did i say you said the last
time
you said i don't remember but you said
something but oh when you spat that was
oh well i didn't plan for that i was
just thinking water and then you
screamed sean
that killed me we've got cam enzymes is
that the battery
that is saddam hussein yeah the man
himself huh yep so let's check it out
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that is so messed up that was genius ugh
i
literally went to youtube
just type random letters the first thing
that popped up it was a video with zero
views it was just uh random saddam
hussein
almost got me because he said hello good
morning in arabic and then it
exactly
you guys don't know the history that's
the one that [ __ ] me up last year yeah
yeah and dan got me again good nobody
else left nobody else gives a [ __ ] i was
so close i was so nobody else
i just find that i find it funny that
the thing that was gonna make you laugh
was an arab video all right does
everyone approve this is a pretty big
bite oh yeah that's sufficient
got that dog food
we gotta get blue buffalo on stomach
what's the yelp review the texture is
[ __ ] horrible
that grape sour the soggy grape nubs is
not it
that's enough already to make me uh
stop zach
nobody asked you to do that
green beans cheese whatever creamy [ __ ]
that is definitely mayo
in your eyes is it cool how could it not
be made why are you closing your eyes
i just kind of go through it yeah
the grape nuts is the worst part
i did it though i ate it
well that's it for me so uh ian do you
want to reveal what this is there's meat
in that
uh yeah so in that one we are talking
green beans grape nuts
clam chowder ew oh my god vegan cheese
sugar and vanilla
the [ __ ] i got a clam on that bite
that was [ __ ] the vanilla lamb i think
the vegan cheese was that clam been
sitting out dude
probably a little too long
yeah i would think so as well
of course i'm though i got the clam by
and no one else probably got a clam by
it
because i was like there's definitely
meat in here i'm hitting something meaty
oh yeah is that something
right there that's like it oh [ __ ] that
it's a little shellfish
yeah that's horrific all right abe
you're next
all right yeah okay dish oh
interesting that looks not bad i mean
you got some mashed potatoes and a gravy
the gravy is a little jiggly yeah it
is a little gelatinous there oh there's
a bug on this one too oh lovely extra
garnier protein get out of there
get the [ __ ] out of here
well there's one in the oh this ain't
right something ain't hearing right
ew what's wrong with you
i think this one is going to be cursed
as hell i can tell you guys enjoy that
that one's definitely cursed it's like
fruit it smells like a air freshener
that's probably the most cursed one yet
like that cherry
i don't trust anything that's chunky and
jiggly that is horrible yeah yeah it's
like sweet smelling and it smells like
vomit and minty
you give it a smell maybe you're not
gonna make me smell it straight up that
just made me gag sniffing that
no
that doesn't make you good you wish you
were here love for this
yeah
i do wish i was there mm-hmm sam just
with him
oh yeah you're like you don't you want
evil librarian
i still have the
last one in my mouth
hit that water boy all right well i have
four shorter videos and one that's a
little bit longer so okay i will not
laugh at this [ __ ] savor it bring on the
heat you guys ready
oh this is almost cheating this is
called this is almost cheating
oh well no has a mohammed has a mental
breakdown oh no not
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
oh my god i can't believe i made it
through that
i i was so close to breaking i was just
about to
oh
wally that's almost cheating to use
mostly with me
i was wow hey i
i was leaning with you i didn't call you
out your shit's playing bro oh wait hold
on a b hold on wait wait hold on what do
you mean a.b
i don't know if i could determine if i
was laughing or not i need one of those
the exhale come on the nose exhale what
do we think sam you're the ref i think
i'll finish dan with the next one he did
like this
like that no it wasn't one of those no
no no no it was not there was no
it was
yeah you can breathe i don't i don't see
anything no breathing
please don't breathe
all right
fair enough ready this one's four hours
long bro no that's not it okay
i don't know
more wall what the wait more wally is it
just going to all be wally no no this is
the last walleye okay
do you want your light
this is
your bad boy
foreign
that's what i think
better than that
i don't even know i just
i get a little bit of that jello and
gelatinous ethan diggin looks like that
you know when you have diarrhea and it's
like mucousy yeah oh
my god it's gonna come out looking the
same yeah it looks like it came out of
someone's nose oh god what it's it's
like toothpastey
i got you guys
sam quiet sam said let's see gravy
there's gravy on here he's got gravy
it's so
strong what did you put in that you foul
witch
[Laughter]
is it peppermint oil uh you know what's
funny and i'm not even making a joke i
was asking sam for toothpaste earlier
because usually we have some in the
office and all of a sudden we couldn't
find it
fascinating
the way that it finishes is beyond
fallon
that is beyond oh my god i'd rather eat
the fika fish than that [ __ ] okay oh my
god
that's the moment
canada you wouldn't don't say that okay
we have the fifa fish we got bloopers
you would rather eat fifa fish than that
that was horrendous
this one is super short the way it
finishes yeah
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
okay i'm not laughing again we have to
watch this twice as like 10 seconds
i'm not laughing it i'm just gonna wait
this is not bad that day no it's not
this is it no no no okay good i wish i
could yeah oh bhagwan i know this guy
yeah she did not prove to be a
she woman to be a perfect [ __ ]
nothing to make me laugh in competition
with that she did not prove to be a
woman
whoever is there
to be a perfect [ __ ] that's a great
documentary yeah serious it was he was
talking about like his partner who
betrayed him mm-hmm
yeah that was crazy
that's a great documentary if you guys
haven't seen it what's it called wild
world country yeah on netflix right
oh oh gosh i want keep it you got to get
one of these guys they got to taste that
abomination of god all right vile you
guys ready
zach hates it
short as well very motivated yeah
exactly you know if zach hated it yeah
i'm so serious right now
i'm not laughing again all right here we
go i'll never laugh again
let me full screen that first here we go
pretty funny
i'm outside it was not what i was
expecting at all
[Applause]
it's pretty funny
all right i'm glad that dan's good
this is fine
oh my god you swallowed it so far dude
oh the linger
oh the link i didn't swallow it oh you
weren't kidding cranberries wrote their
song about that i did it fast i wouldn't
be able to get past it it did not help
okay
so that's the worst thing you've ever
that is the worst
thing ever dude it's like stuck in my
throat it's horrendous it's [ __ ] like
the sticky we need a medic
right
i sell y'all never laugh again
so that's like all humor in life that's
like drinking like a cup full of
toothpaste pit
yeah yeah it's like the [ __ ] you put
your retainer in
yeah
all right so all the videos were short
so that this one could be a little
longer okay god i hate that on the show
we reacted to a ugandan uh interview
where someone uh the interviewer was
trying to understand a gentleman who
came in and was explaining that uh he
was transgender and he kept asking
the interviewer was trying to understand
uh the sexuality of this gay yes why are
you transgender now we've never watched
the full clip so who is gay and this is
the it's not the full thing but it's a
little bit longer
this is great and yeah and it also
brings in the preacher from the eat the
poopoo
i'm almost paused that yeah
yeah wait they're in the video actually
together yeah how fast i'm almost
positive this is the same guy okay
the guy interviewing no no not that no
this is going to be broadband you are
transgender yes so who is gay
i skipped past that part because we're
all familiar but i could show that if
you guys want to start there no no i
mean we've all seen a million dollars
you are a transgender and you're a gay
rights activist and an outspoken um uh
uh
lesbian
homosexual
how can i describe you why should
someone be gay so as we stand today are
you dating any female
yes i am do you perform the natural
obligations doesn't that make you gay
what do you mean doesn't that make me
gay i am i am male 1 people are from
like two different universes of you
trying to understand each other and this
guy seems like a dick at first and he
may be oh yeah
but he's really genuinely trying to
understand that's what i mean he's
actually kind of sweet in his his
ignorance and how did he feel he's
trying he's just he genuinely wants to
understand being gay then
don't you think
guys homosexuals lesbians uh
transgenders should instead be
reoriented
other than uh receiving all this kind of
recognition because society seems to
deem them as unnatural as people who are
maybe lost
there is nothing natural about cooking
oh it
because nature cannot allow you what do
you mean nature cannot allow me
i am attracted to someone sexually
that is nature allowing me
this why do you recruit young boys
into into this gay activism i want you
to tell me
or when you having intercourse with a
fellow man or a fellow woman is there
only one way to have children is there
only one yes there is
legally
is there any good justification for
homosexuality now the
they're oh
i'm a human race defender priest comes
in i'm tasting that oh [ __ ] my mouth
still i'm not um i see pasta sempers
come here i love that yeah i had to come
to this show
i spoke to you
no he cannot just tell me so
i stood out she thinks she's a man but
she does not have the equipment to be a
man so what do they do
to be able to try and penetrate the
other person they use carrots because
it's a carrot watch it up backwards
okay
i think you're being illiterate no no no
no backwards
when you use something like this
so when you use something like this and
you put it inside you
you rip your urinary tract areas
when they put it inside they're behind
now whatever chris movie room
okay
yes
you eat them on your plate yes you don't
use them when you're having candle
knowledge what sodomy is about confusion
a banana is different from a cucumber i
have a carrot is different from a banana
i want you to understand some good ones
then they come and tell me what is going
on but they are giving themselves here
trying to figure out
do you have fathers and grandfathers do
you eat carrots so then so then that
means okay what do they use for what
what the what do you use ginger what do
you use the carrots all the corn
my food you see they don't even want to
talk about okay
when you take a man
this is a man's genitals and you insert
them into and the the intestine okay
they put their genitals into the
excretory system this excretory system
is not designed to receive
it is only the exit okay so they don't
have enough cells bro is they begin want
their sexual acts because she does not
have the equipment
they begin to use their lips so the
mouth is used to lick the other person
that's number one because they don't
have the equipment avicora they begin to
use gadgets like bananas they use
carrots they use bananas they use
cucumbers and other metallized ones and
they put them inside themselves
you
[Music]
so you use the carrot so who's
transgender
yucky you are gay if you use the carrot
the top comment on the video was i
wonder if the interviewer knows how
famous he is
i still tasting that and i'm just yeah
it's a reminder that's the worst thing
i've ever had yeah it really is so much
and it's still in my mouth
well
is that it yeah i just wanted an excuse
to watch the rest of that video i was
always curious well it was really
interesting that the the eat the pupu
guy yeah yeah
that's a that's a crossover episode
right there that's awesome
so who is gate all right please
i'm just i'm sad that uh not everyone
got to try yeah i know
you guys you want to take a dive
oh no no no
was one part worse than the other part
i think it took i i it's hard to tell
what was worse if you i'll i'll try it
the aftertaste for real
yeah give this yeah you're a just little
leg but that's total legend status
we love that we love that i'll do it if
ap does it too nope nope okay oh he is
not allowed to do it there will be vom
in the studio
yeah well i mean there's no garlic
baby bro i got a weak stomach i'll join
you plain
that's a good cam's taking it on no i'm
not i'm okay
they're used to it yeah i'm not
i just share my seat ready cheers cheers
thank you guys you guys are i just i
think it's so brave of you guys to but
to eat this because it's really are you
eating
it's really creatively bad mm-hmm
it swallowed it like medicine oh dude
it's like an explosion of all the bad
flavors you can think of yeah
oh my god it's immediate
that's why i i thought i was
i was like i could just get this down
quick it won't be that bad but the the
aftertaste is horrendous that's where
they get you horrendous yeah it's the
worst thing ever so are you guys gonna
explain what's in it um yeah good job
you guys first of all cam and olivia
well done
love that for you guys
uh so yeah sam is a real artist in here
with this the gravy is red bull and
gravy powder oh red bull
and then the mashed potatoes
uh potatoes peppermint
onion powder and blue cheese
so it's definitely the peppermint and
the red bull is like
i still have it in my mouth yeah that's
it's not going i want to eat one of the
other ones now to like i need something
it's the red
evil come on
give it a little taste a b a b a b a b a
b don't give in to peer pressure kids oh
wow okay his version of the mile high
club is going to be [ __ ] on spirits
oh i'm part of that mile hog club zach
is next cool you want to come sure we'll
swap all right so amy left before we
could get him to try the
he bailed so fast he was not having it
nope
and um
i gotta tell you that last dish with the
mashed potatoes i can't get rid of the
flavor same i'm never eating or laughing
again yeah it was horrendous i tried i
started drinking
coke i tried eating a little something
and i just cannot get rid of that flavor
i just it's so [ __ ]
i told sam she's not invited in my
birthday party next year
[Laughter]
your birthday is next week no next year
go next year that's how mad at you
you're planning
all right what do we got here sam what
what is this abomination
so this next one is uh ambrosia salad
which is normally made with uh
sort of marshmallows of fruit fruit base
pineapple
orange slices things like that sounds
good yeah it does
want to grab a shot of it
oh right but right oh is abey's camera
so here we've got what looks like cheese
marshmallow i know what it is it's
[ __ ] mayonnaise that of like whipped
cream right oh boy cheese
evil i don't even want to say
i smell the mayo i'm so messed up from
that last one that i'm gonna smell it
just for tradition
there's little chunks of something
interesting i mean like uh
it just smells like mayo isn't like
potato salad and stuff you usually have
man so you know maybe it won't be that
it looks like imitation crap i take it
back that's awful
it just smells like mayo it looks great
to me
with the i mean if no the cheese i don't
know no it doesn't it doesn't look great
to me
come to papa
is it cheese of course
it looks like imitation crab yeah that's
what i thought you were saying that
makes it look like cheese i hope it's
not crab is there crab in this
okay no no crap not bad so can i get one
of you are ian to try the [ __ ] mashed
potatoes
you guys deserve to be
inflicted with that maybe at the end
okay
maybe yeah that's not because ab bailed
before we could he didn't he didn't even
eat anything he bailed
he's like all right well i gotta go guys
little [ __ ] smart smart man all right
zach let's see what you got okay i'm
never laugh i'm not laughing nothing
will ever make me laugh again
so good luck
okay so
one of my uh new favorite videos okay
[Music]
okay
what is the slide
oh
[Music]
we're gonna i get another replay
that was
the kid's reaction to the laugh was
great
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
no laughter
nothing no no it didn't get me
underneath it's close though interesting
i did crack a smile okay yeah yeah
pretty sure
i think that's it my tick tock likes
actually you had the advantage you'd
seen it mm-hmm okay we gotta
we got home yeah this is interesting
it's gonna make me 51 years old
oh can you full screen or zoom in
i want to get those i'm already about to
laugh
love all the angles this is artistic
[Music]
it's like a bill wurtz kind of
i love all the angles there he make
himself a birthday tick tock
he's 51 years young today
[Music]
all right you can't keep making it look
you you got you got your shot all right
come on you laugh no cause you
i thought we had a one replay rule but
okay all right i'll go for it yeah
this is for henry then happy birthday
henry happy birthday henry although i
will say it didn't say he was 51 years
old he just said 51 years yeah oh yeah
he's just he's just he's just letting
him
go
51 years it's a dating profile henry 51.
what the hell is this do i eat this it
might be coconut should i try to get one
of those red things in there it's just a
cherry yeah bro my stomach is oh there
you go
there's some [ __ ] up dark arts going
on right here
happy
thanksgiving legend goodbye a goodbye
you're a good man cam
walk us through it
it's pretty sweet i mean
actually something just hit me i don't
like it at first it was fine with the
cherry yeah the cherry probably
dominated
[ __ ] oh no you didn't try the mashed
potatoes did you he did he did he did
how does it compare
not as bad but not wow i'm gonna be
shocked if anything tops those mashed
potatoes was it cheese in this this is
second to the mashed potatoes in my bowl
what's the chunky thing in there is it
cheese
the white chunky thing yeah i think
that's a marshmallow no no the little
shredded bits
oh it could be coconut there's a whole
lot of mystery going on right now i
can't it's too much to do i can see
coconut being thrown in there wicked
awful kid it's wicked [ __ ] awful dude
okay
all right keep it rolling keep it
rolling i'm not laughing for the rest of
the day after that mashed potatoes i'll
tell you right now that [ __ ] just hit
wrong yeah i don't recommend laughing
for this
check out this roundhouse kick oh i saw
a little roadhouse action
[Laughter]
all humor is gone from my life
okay not nothing whatever tough crowd
before i even think of laughing i can
feel the peppermint
yeah so okay it will not leave my mouth
you're definitely working with a
handicap here tough crowd exactly yeah
tough coming after that following up
that mashed potato
okay
tough ground okay this this one might
get you ethan
this one the ending alone
why are you calling me out
just because i'm a tough competitor
today
[Music]
oh there it is
[Music]
what kind of train is this you just got
oh damn i love that he's like my brother
we made it he popped a wheelie
oh did he i'm glad i didn't notice that
because that probably would have got me
[Music]
[Music]
he's
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] yeah i missed that the first time
kind of badass
like i said there's no humor left in my
life i like the celebration yeah me too
i like that clip
okay whatever wait is that tweeted by
the wu-tang clan i think it's just like
a
wu-tang kids oh between kids okay oh
wait no yeah it's their token actually
save the wood 10 kids
and then uh for the last one
personal favorite
more ugandan
no i don't know why that's on the screen
but we need to praise our lord and
savior young cena
unfortunately you're the only one that
finds this one really funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm just thinking of the original video
of him apologizing
[Music]
you remember the original video though
think about the original i'm so so sorry
you have to understand i love china
young cena my dad
the surprise factor's gone that's that's
what almost got me i'm gonna i'm i want
to make that my new wallpaper
anyways thank god because i really
didn't want to do that john cena more
like john
what's the name of that more like john
cea
jung cena see like c
uh like yeah
later emperor's name like c g or
something the emperor xi jinping
whatever the chairman
the ruler i have one more
um it kind of goes five right it kind of
it kind of is the same thing though go
ahead okay thank you this is the i had a
six and i skipped it i already know it
um
i'm dead i'm serious i'm deadly serious
like i will never laugh again hmm
[Music]
don't you feel stupid
ethan's so close
[Music]
the two kids was so good don't you feel
killing me
[Music]
the two kids thing was so funny yeah
yeah the plus 100 social credits
does that count as the left for uh cam
i'm gonna i wanna
you're going to try it willingly zach's
taking my place for it all right that
take the bullet for cam he's like your
champion right
go ahead zacky trial
that's a big ass bite go for it
get some cherry in there
no dude get the cherry in there that's
part of the experience you want the
cherry yeah the cherry is gonna squish
do i also want to try it go for it i'm
not i'm not i think you want to try it i
don't think you would have said that if
you didn't want to try it i think that's
maybe i'll be proud of you it looks good
i'm proud of you for like of all of them
that one looks the most legit
like that would catch somebody off guard
uh
yeah i mean you could prank somebody
with it for sure that's what i mean like
yeah i mean you don't even have to tell
you whatever you want to see
whoa whoa zach you couldn't have held
that for like one second longer she was
about to take a big old bite what
happened you want to talk us through it
what's happening it's like the
mayonnaise separated from everything
else and just went straight to my
stomach i thought you're the mayo boy
come on
maybe craft did make the right yeah you
would use spoonful yeah maybe make the
right decision yeah look at you they
[ __ ] me so hard i was losing your [ __ ]
proud of you for that
yum yum
well you were the one that was talking
up how good it looks though
[Laughter]
you know what i chased it with the
cherry
carrot did hurt but i think that's
what's separated
oh it's coconut good okay i hate coconut
can i can i speak speaking of craft
mayonnaise you know like gift card they
gave me doesn't [ __ ] work no
[ __ ] what oh so they give you a coupon
for craft mail
and you actually tried to redeem it no
no you try and redeem it like at a
grocery store and they were like what
the [ __ ] is this they gave me a 100
visa gift card right and i called
to activate it they're like oh this [ __ ]
doesn't work what there's like no
balance on them
that's so shady
they couldn't even pony up a hundred
bucks for you they [ __ ] me we need
justice we need
okay so we need to how do we get justice
for this this is a lawsuit i feel like
yeah
yeah
i you know it's like
they need you know what i'm gonna do
don't let them knock all over you like
i'm gonna tweet them right now and you
guys if you guys want to get involved
but this is just
it's outrageous
okay so at craft mail
it just doesn't work cash boy
for my hundo yeah or the benjamin adams
it's not showing up did they block me or
something
that real crap mayonnaise a real craft
man is it a hundred or a thousand
hundred
[Music]
did they really it's real craft mail
they had like a thousand followers
yeah they're probably all our fans too
because we talked about them so much i
still every so often i'll check in on
their instagram and they still get zach
comments on oh yeah yeah appreciate the
fun
i found them real craft mayo all right
listen up you [ __ ] degeneres
yo you guys
you guys
really sent
zach
a
[ __ ]
gift card
after everything
he did for you i called i followed all
the procedures i called i activated it
i go to a store it doesn't [ __ ] work
i've printed it
you know what you not only do they owe
you a hundred now they owe you painted
suffering and an apology how much do you
want to make this right like 500 a rolex
okay
a male role i just another gift card
would be great you owe him a new gift
card
double double it yeah i think that's
fair double it for pain and soft eye for
eye 200 bucks kota hammurabi
[ __ ]
makes the whole 100
also [ __ ] also [ __ ] uh bar stool sparks
yeah
dave pork boy yes because they [ __ ]
be as [ __ ] bar stool
it's just like i couldn't believe it
they [ __ ] me once and they're [ __ ]
me here's my tweet yo you guys really
sent zak a [ __ ] gift card after
everything he did for you owe him a new
gift card double it for paying it
suffering 200 pay up right now ps [ __ ]
bart's little sports can you hit him
with the hell i feel like they might not
understand that the gift card that they
sent
was not functioning
like that just kind of sounds like
you're just complaining
that someone just sent them a gift card
laying around the damn office they'll
know when they watch this can you hear
them i appreciate that can you hit him
with a hashtag hellman's at the end of
that tweet too
oh hashtag hellman's boy
hellman spokesperson
hellman's
hashtag hellman's
is hashtag real mayo
for real men well real men real men real
men what do we do real people where
would we be without helmets
real mail for real people [ __ ] you
keep it inclusive helens would never he
before
ever almonds would never okay so what do
we got here in the ambrosia
uh so it looks like for that one it was
pineapple cherries
mayonnaise pecans and coconut oh so it's
coconut that's the shredded mm-hmm yeah
so it sounds like if it was just like
whipped cream instead of mayo that'd be
a nice dish yeah definitely
traditionally
it's traditionally with whipped cream
evil ass put [ __ ] mayonnaise in it
you know what i'm still suffering from
that
it's not going away no from the from the
uh in the back of my throat
i'm just i'm suffering i think because
it's so slimy it's i think it's
literally like still just kind of
gooping down
peppermint oil in it
which is even worse yeah yes the extract
is just it's like sticking to my like
the [ __ ] you put in the diffuser it's
very potent
like vanilla extract that was just
horrible yeah but i praise you for your
evilness and yeah all right thank you
next up next up you're up next right cam
grants okay
all right looks like we've got a nice
traditional uh pumpkin pie classic
thanksgiving beautiful
now i've been informed that uh
this has some sort of meat product in it
so if i am to break we have an alternate
here like cranberry yeah kind of
cranberry sauce will be up next as well
for everybody just in case just in case
yeah so that pumpkin pie looks like
deceptively normal knowing there's meat
in it is a little disturbing yeah
but um
let's take it a sniff i guess
actually looks good
hot sauce or something
oh interesting i think foul is something
i mean it's definitely not it's brisket
it's just a little off southern twang it
tastes obviously like salty not sweet
like barbecue yeah it's barbecuey
yeah this goes because i remember when
we did this last and we had the pumpkin
pie with the mayo yeah the pumpkin
flavor in pumpkin pie is so strong that
it wasn't actually like i was
good but it like i was down with it it
wasn't as bad as you'd think because the
pumpkin kind of overpowered the
mayonnaise flavor but
um
sam is a mad genius so you like sausage
i'm not laughing i'm telling you there's
no laughter left in my life after those
mashed potatoes
we'll i'm just sour i'm angry i'm
worried about cam because cam and i
giggle at the same videos usually right
yeah i mean cam got always got some
weird [ __ ] up his sleeve i'm determined
so i mean i got a variety of content
going for this one so let's start it off
with this one okay we got a little
minecraft me a little sweet a little
sour
yeah see how this goes
minecraft memes
looks like the two this is all foreign
we're going to send him to space
this is a flying machine
and gavin's going to fly
little psycho girl where'd you find her
to do this machine
mumbo jumbo
i see he's very helpful
should send him a thank you note yeah
we're almost done
just gotta get this observer
and now he flies
look at him go
he's so
happy gavin always wanted to fly
nobody all right nada it was just a nice
wholesome video yeah it was nice i was
hoping that the punch line at the end
would get somebody's a surprise but
that's okay
gavin the pig we gotta send him to space
galvin he's always wanted to fly i knew
something horrible was gonna happen to
gavin so yeah i was waiting for it yeah
yeah maybe it maybe just caught me off
guard when i popped up on my tick tock
so i mean i cracked a smile but so it
didn't quite get me let me go for the
complete
opposite end of the uh comedy spectrum
now and get okay dark and cursed with it
oh this is right off my uh cursed tick
tock feet so enjoy
four
four gentlemen looking for love oh my
goodness look at that dome
i
will [ __ ] you
hot romantic hard
romantic
so here's the deal
i got you six
that ain't a question
have you got mine
good
jacob davis swears every time he
squeezes your lumptuous ass
orange juice is gonna come pouring out
ew
what
you guys both yeah yeah we got you guys
the first one we played again i just
want to see like the first one
okay four gentlemen looking for love did
you make this yeah these are great yeah
i i
just certified lover boys yeah the name
of this video
i
will [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
hard definitely
the last guy he went viral for one about
like a turkey baster or something like
that that was my first interaction yeah
okay so dan is going for the alternate
uh cranberry cranberry sauce it's pretty
just
pretty liquidy yeah this is like a goop
you want to hand me the spoonful the
pumpkin a little bit of a
nyquil eh yeah i was just thinking it
looks like a
spoonful of menace so go ahead dan
put that nyquil down
wow you took a little taste he looks
like he likes it is this spicy
oh maybe not well like i don't know i
don't even know what's going on there
you seemed like you liked it at first
hang on zach listen oh it is developing
oh no it is developing spicy or what i
can't i
i'm baffled i i don't even begin to have
a guess of what's in there is it gross
kind of
whoa
like it was kind of good
at first yeah you seem stoked on it but
then the the the flavor it's it's it's
sliding downhill as as time zack i see
you inspecting your digging through that
pumpkin pie what's going on there i i
can't even i can't even begin to fathom
what that is that was one of the
weirdest things what are you doing
interesting there's like something in
here
we'll take a bite of it he's digging for
treasure it looks like anchovy or some
[ __ ] good luck oh no anchovy it's tuna
oh no
you know what this is actually pretty
good no
well i'm not gonna try it like a squash
mashed potato i'm going for a round here
goes zach for the second bite of tuna
pumpkin pie it's not bad i hate tuna so
i'm not [ __ ] wrong with i'm not eat
i'm not taking another bite of anything
that's my pledge god i hope i can get
you i'm hoping no it's [ __ ] i'm sorry
that pumpkin that pump or the [ __ ]
mashed potato stole the joy for my life
yeah
that is so too now you're right it's
tuna eew
tuna fish
yeah i mean
what i what the [ __ ] is that though i
couldn't figure it out either
like earlier i like
it almost tastes like a
like maybe
sweet and sour but like oh but then
mixed with something totally left field
i really don't know i really don't know
horseradish okay well go ahead
and it was like
it was spicy but but also super sweet it
could be horseradish that's a good guy
yeah so
i hope i don't have to all
right oh this is a
like a leaf flower in the house
damn even the dog got caught
i'm gonna play it one more game pretty
funny
[Music]
oh weird
didn't know something weird
and a hole that'll drill in your skull
is that it no i guess yeah just why all
right now now that's kind of [ __ ] up
all of these have have a
very interesting journey of flavor that
it takes you on
i feel like it's still developing in my
mouth yeah that's minutes later that's
[ __ ] up dude yeah these are all new
flavors in our mouths you got mark ham
yep i got a couple more i don't know
this is a classic right here this is
nothing like uh straight from my curse
tick tock account but this is a classic
rwanda or ronda oh [ __ ] oh glove knows
it killed me with a stone my favorite he
loves it
as you guys can see
[Applause]
look he killed me with the stone a stone
he can't use a stone
yeah guys look
yeah yeah look guys look look
[Applause]
hey disconnected yeah guys
thanks for watching guys
i heard a laugh did somebody laugh
that's pretty i was very close
and he gets a replay it reminds me of
these i don't know if you've seen these
memes of like old fat guys weighing
themselves and the the
the uh reflection of the weight you can
see the little tiny penis
this just this was nostalgic for me it
reminded me
that's funny
yeah
you've your summers as a kid yeah
gaming out over the summer and you're in
there did anyone anyone laugh while that
one the hot summer day oh i was so close
that really caught me off guard well i'm
going in totally different directions
i'm gonna use my replay real quick yeah
as you guys can see
he can't use the stone
yeah guys he's covering his face like
what yeah yeah look guys look look
hey disconnected yeah guys
thanks for watching guys
you're welcome
yeah
i can't believe i did that i think um
i think you're just not supposed to use
stuns on one one-on-one mode or
something yeah you're using stunts in
the sniper match damn dude oh
oh
i see i say i see i see
that guy that guy that got caught on
camera must be so embarrassed yeah for
sure he was using a stun on camera
oh my gosh this one i feel like ethan
i'm hoping this is my hail mary pass
okay
this one i i put in here just for you
because i figured
y'all appreciate it
let's go
i found this old video of my bus monitor
literally flying in the falcon
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing i still got that
i found this old video of my bus monitor
literally flying in the falcon air when
we hit a bump
look at that
no that's crazy nothing
it's a lot of air that's a good thing
that loves it
well bottoms up
can i try that
it's coming up that's the next round
round so you got a chance
yeah you get it you had to go on for the
second bite this is [ __ ] said it
wasn't bad
yeah but now it's [ __ ] up wait you're
just eating the crust bro hold on
yeah the crust is the best part you have
to get that
it's [ __ ] up is there something
special about the crust sam no no it's
just crushed
zach is not loving that third bite
that's good yeah
oh that was his third time too well he
ate he took two bites the first time oh
joker brown cam what do you want from me
all right joker brain
proud of myself keeping it together
because leave it
cam that's like the funniest [ __ ] i've
ever seen thanks
all right good job
olivia
up next wait
i think we already know but we go ahead
yeah with the description of the pumpkin
pie yep
okay
uh so this was listed as surf and turf
pumpkin ew
uh it's old bay uh pumpkin and buffalo
tuna
what was the first ingredient old bay
the [ __ ] is
it's a seasoning what's old bay
oh it's a seafood seasoning sam said
nice
god i got it old bay wait blue blue
buffalo tuna
oh
blue buffalo yeah yeah round goes around
everything yeah everything goes all
right get the get the get this [ __ ] out
of here all right up next thank you
okay so this round we have the uh
cranberry sauce that dan's described it
looks pretty wild
yeah and it's a wild ride
according to dan
so um
i'm not laughing i'm not looking for
round two
you're not looking for round two not
necessarily yeah no because you seem
kind of mixed on it i mean
it's not a thing experience it's not as
bad as the mashed potatoes yeah nothing
nothing has come remotely close to that
but nothing in my life has come as bad
you see my mood changed after that yeah
you completely actually would say this
one
is
odd enough that i would almost encourage
everybody to laugh at least once give it
a shot
it's not like
it's not as um
horrific as everything else that we've
tasted i'm not it's more just weird
hear that guys not that horrific not
that horrific just a little weird weird
would would you eat a jelly belly jelly
bean made out of that
what
jelly belly makes weird [ __ ] flavors
i don't know i mean i guess okay
all right
okay
okay whatever
all right olivia what we got i'm
interested
you're a little bit of a wild card i
know about these guys what kind of they
bring to the table in terms of their
sense of humor i'm very curious what
you've got for us
that made me ten times more nervous okay
here we go
this is a popular one here we go a
million likes
wanted to clarify this is a copper
exfoliating mask that i needed to dry so
i can get my dunkin faster
[Music]
that's awesome
she got bronzer on no she put a copper
exfoliating face mask on she do edit
herself
so that was her original if you try to
click on this video it is deleted
yeah i imagine she got she dragged on
for a block base or something yes so she
was just trying to get her duncans early
she's trying to get over to dunking i
need my face mask to dry it's time to go
to dunkins oh my god
wanted to clarify this is a copper
exfoliating music choice that i needed
to dry so i could get it
faster what is that thing she's using
that's a diffuser and hair dryer
i guarantee she voted trump by the way
there's no way she didn't i love that
one i didn't laugh but i love that video
yeah that is awesome the dubstep got me
yeah
you have a nice little swig there buddy
do i what do i do with this just for
just double click the top yeah just full
screen exactly
yeah that's fine you don't need a lot
trust me just that's fine
bottoms up a dab will do you
[Music]
thoughts
prayers
i'm with dan this is a weird this is a
weird [ __ ] taste right what the [ __ ]
is this
there's like this thing
interesting thing you guys have cocked
up sounds like a potion is that a health
function yeah what is this man what's
that alpha brain it's is this alpha
brain i imagine this is probably what
this is what i pissed about
yeah it put it in your cranberry sauce
exactly yeah
but good stuff
number two
am i able to full screen her yeah
this is my favorite thing that's ever
happened
my mom made this video to show her
facebook friends this cool trick wow
this is going oh boy oh boy so does
anyone oh my god
welcome to my world oh my god that is a
cool trick
thank you
yes so
let's try again that was good yeah new
video
[Applause]
trader one's in on this trader you want
in on this
i like this boomer [ __ ] though i'll tell
you here we go
so does anyone buy the kind of peanut
butter that doesn't have all the
additives so the oil is separated and
when you open it you have to mix it
well that kind of like is a really
crappy task and it drives me nuts so
here's what i do
put only one beater in
the a hand beater this is going to go
off stick it in
and you're going to want to really hold
on to that jar because it's going gonna
wanna take it out of your hands and
watch
like
that
she barely held on to that jar you could
tell
a handful and she did it twice and stick
it in
and you're gonna want to really hold on
hold on tight look at her hands he's
gonna want to take it out of your hands
and watch
like
that that's good that's good
i can't believe it take a big bite there
dan cause you you only did half frost i
know but you only ate half of it last
time
i've been thinking about how to describe
it the whole time see
you
trust me it's so strong you only need
the slightest amount
you're like
no just try it just no just
if you don't laugh i have a bonus video
that i need okay go ahead
i feel like i'm impenetrable right now
okay impregnable this was
my favorite video growing up and it
still makes me laugh go ahead and see
what we got yep
okay
this girl is sneezing with her eyes open
oh okay no
this is her objective mm-hmm oh she's
put a little something in her nose to
make her sneeze interesting she's trying
to sneeze with her eyes open
oh my god why is she doing this
so close to her face
[Music]
why is she doing this
do it again do it again do it again
she did it though she did yeah
all right
she proved this all wrong he did people
say i can't sneeze
with their eyes open and she proved us
all wrong
oh [ __ ] i got it oh that's never coming
out
[Music]
just tastes like cayenne pepper you guys
are tripping
no no way no way yeah
that's something you put on egg rolls
man
it's not bad yeah it's not bad that's
what i was saying it tastes like a sauce
but a sauce you would never want to eat
by itself can you have me a napkin sir
it's like a sauce that you would never
want to eat by itself obviously but to
me it's like you know
chili powder
it's chili powder it's paprika it's
stuff like that okay
you know mixed with
the base is probably cranberry i think
there actually is cranberries yeah it's
super sour i guess that's maybe why yeah
what's like throwing me for a loop there
well it reminds me of
there's these little mexican candies as
a kid that i hated but some people loved
i love those it reminds me of that hmm
it's a little reminiscent of those
i know what you're talking about and
yeah
feel free to giggle
thank you thank you thank you for the
permission
oh you guys might like this
a teleporting effect okay
where's it gonna teleport me to
i hope to my camera roll
a teleporting effect okay oh my god or
is it gonna teleport me to
oh to my camera
a teleporting that's really good
that's really good
thank you
that's that's good that was hard that
was that was hard there yeah all right
here is the last one
last one i love this video
that was a very good video
hitler he said he'd had an emergency
defecation situation and needed to
choose her bathroom but the judge in the
case found he had a sexual motive
[Music]
an emergency
[Laughter]
because this next story is so tragic i
cannot be laughing right
investigators believe a bomb caused the
explosion on a plane which is just taken
off from the somali capital of mogadishu
the blast blew a hole in the side of the
planet
there was no violent decompression
[Music]
very good very good very good i was
going to say this is almost a dd
megadoodle moment yeah exactly
definitely a dd megadoodle
[Music]
third [ __ ] thing of this let's say dd
megadoo it's that that one oh i know her
yeah
i have watched all of these compilations
yeah these are good they're good
yeah it tastes like something you put on
an egg roll
it's like
sour celery that's what each one is
worse
worse than the last one all right so so
are we done is that it so what do you
want me to show you the bonus ones oh
sure yeah okay this one up
i
deleted yeah there's a lot going on in
my mouth right now it's a lot going on
well describe to us so what what is in
this ian
uh so this one
is was ethan wright did he call it it is
cranberry sauce with well
cranberry base
sugar
spicy tomato juice and fish sauce oh my
spicy tomato juice hmm fish i didn't
notice the fish sauce yeah
interesting the fish sauce i did not i
didn't get that one that's the [ __ ] i
put on the soggy waffle
oh right flashback soggy waffle that's a
different game yeah limp bizkit actually
okay are you ready yep
a little bonus round oh
come on this is cheating yes this is
well this is what i did to you
this is my true test so you guys can see
just how [ __ ] i am from those mashed
potatoes
i'm not laughing
[Music]
see how joyless i am now damn wow well
i'm glad i got you on
on my true videos so yeah you got me you
got me you definitely got me all right
so now
that we've completed this yeah i got a
second comment anybody coming from the
history podcast huh
90 likes shout out
okay so now i gotta get i have to get
ian in here and sam if possible to try
those mashed potatoes
[ __ ] sam says she's tasting him
did you taste it on camera
all right ian get over here
the more the more people that take did
everyone here taste it i did not
you guys well you guys want to give it a
taste oh that i didn't the mashed
potatoes oh i tried the mash yeah we all
did except for a b for the
next all right so we're doing a little
bonus clip ian was kind enough to come
out here and
take a bite of the mashed potatoes and
gravy let me see the let me just verify
yeah that looks like a good that's a
good healthy bite can i look too yeah
zach wants to verify
verify
zach needs to inspect are you gonna do a
taste test
what is this there's like nothing in
here no that's fine you know what
while i'm here oh i have the tallies of
who broke the most oh interesting dan
with six
wait dan won no dan laughed six times he
broke six times cam was six
olivia with two baby with zero because
he ran out
ethan with three and zach with eight
hold on hold on
olivia did two olivia won
oh i guess wow impressive it appears
like she did okay
congratulations
olivia's the victor you know um
i'm proud of myself after last year was
such a pathetic showing i did better
good job congrats why don't you why
don't you join us
well maybe you should hit a bike since
you lost i'm not hitting this [ __ ] again
i don't think sam wants to take a bite
i did not see that happen but ian is
doubting that sam tried it
she said ian was at home you have to
rethought to that i don't he doesn't
have a response to that
mad scientist in the lab okay now you
deal with the consequence of this [ __ ]
this is just it's still in my mouth it's
ruined my day
by week you ruined the man's
thanksgiving ian i didn't laugh can we
save some for a b when he gets back too
i swear to god he he just ran out of
here it's not fair when he was here he
goes i got to be out here by 3 45 to
make my flight
he was more expressed than his jacket
all right ian thank you you're a good
sport
again
i mean dude i seen you eat that fish i
can't top that that was the most foul
should i've seen in my life
you tell me and tell me if it how's it
compared to the fish because let me look
at the ingredients
no don't look well you're still eating
it
hmm
it's [ __ ] up dude i mean ian again he
ate that whole cat or a whole fish from
the swiss and swarma or whatever had he
called love
so strong yes sue strowman yeah but that
came up just as quick as it went down to
for him
is that
it's that peppermint that gets ya you
know
distilled red bull yeah that's
do you want to chase it with that some
of that i'm good how's that do for you
it's kind of like like
you know like your
salad tossing santa claus
and just pardon
that's what it tastes like
licking santa claus is that god yeah
it's got this like pepper mini
burning how does it compare to the
swedish fish
that's
yeah that's all you cannot yeah so
that's like giving santa a rim job as
well that's what i'm getting at yeah wow
yeah but
i don't know
it's it's it's not too bad it's that
it's that too maybe you didn't get
enough gravy on it no way he's going for
a second
wow i'm impressed
this man just came in and i feel like
i'm brushing my teeth
yeah it doesn't feel safe for
consumption you're brushing your stomach
acid it's like you're just eating a
bunch of fluoride the blue cheese all
that
no that hit worse
yeah i think the first bite wasn't oh
ian the man
[Laughter]
all right so listen guys
this is our thanksgiving uh special
coming out on thanksgiving i hope you
guys enjoyed the show i hope you had a
fantastic thanksgiving yourself
thanks for watching we'll be back on uh
friday
for after dark live
and that's about it for us so
happy thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
everybody
[Music]